[Music]
hello there you're watching the press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive it's time to
see what's making the headlines with the
daily mirror columnist susie boniface
and the editor of the jewish chronicle
jake wallace simons they'll be with us
from now until just before midnight
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages
the mirror reports on the public
backlash over the downing street
christmas party saying four in five are
less likely to follow covert rules
because of it amid rising rates of
infection
questions over flat refurbishment
spending add to boris johnson's woes
ahead of an approaching by-election in
tomorrow's financial times
the times can reveal pub passports and
daily tests are among measures being
considered to curb the spread of covet
19.
top health officials advise tough curbs
by next week in a leaked government memo
that's on the front of the guardian
the telegraph pleased with the prime
minister to put pupils education first
keep the schools open come what made
their headline there
booster can stop omicron the eye says
three doses of the vaccine are effective
in stopping 75 of symptomatic infections
vaccines do work on the omicron strain
that's on the front of the sun which
also encourages all to get their booster
jabs ahead of the 1 million expected
cases by january 2022
the daily mail also advocates for an
increased booster vaccine uptake saying
two astrazeneca jabs aren't enough to
fend off the omicron variant
the daily express shares concerns over
the spread of the new variant boosters
can beat omicron tsunami
and finally from the star
you dirty rotters a gang of bloodthirsty
otters tried to kill a brighty on a park
stroll
joined tonight by suzy boniface and jake
wallace simons thank you both for
joining us let's kick off with the front
of the express
and this news that
boosters
can
bring down um symptomatic infection of
this omicron variant
susie
yeah so it's good news in a sense that
we we have a new horrible variant with
many more mutations 50 odd more
mutations
uh than we've seen uh pre in previous
variants i think the delta strain the
beta strain they have sort of six varia
six mutations ten mutations on them this
one's got fifty and then they're in the
difficult
on the spike protein on the bit you
really don't want things to be too
mutated because that's the bit the
vaccines target and unfortunately all
the vaccines we've had up till now were
designed for the first strain the wuhan
strain
beta and delta came along and gamma of
course and we managed to cope with those
they managed to deal with them because
there weren't too many mutations but
omicron has is such a super mutant it's
got so many mutations that the vaccines
there's only two of them it doesn't give
you quite enough protection so they do
know some real world data that's come
out now they do know that if you have a
third booster
then your chances of of having some
success against that variant are very
very high and it's going to protect you
from having serious illness and uh
protect you from being too symptomatic
that's all great news because we know
about it the problem is this country's
booster program
and on the front of the newspapers today
you'll see there's lots of stuff about
the boosters will save you the boosters
will be fine and dandy and you know you
can have the boosters in three months
that's the new government rules bloody
blah i'm due my booster today it ran out
today my my jab it was six months ago
today now i've been trying for two
months to get my booster according to
the government rules as soon as they had
these headlines saying you can go into a
walk-in center you can book after five
months you can book after three months
you go down that walk-in center you go
to a pharmacy and they will say we love
to we would love to give you a vaccine
booster but unfortunately
we haven't been sent the guidance
through from the government yet and they
are cancelling appointments and
anecdotally you hear it from lots of
different places and what's happened is
unfortunately the government has gone
for the headline before they've got the
organization in place so people are not
qualifying yet in some cases they boost
until the new year
and people like me who need their boost
and who want their booster who have been
told they can't have it when they should
be having it and the organization the
logistics the vaccine centers they're
just not where they were uh over the
summer and over the spring when we had
that big massive roll out the
organization's changed and it's not
there and here we are facing a big wave
of a new variant that really needs that
booster and it's not quite there yet and
it's a shame that some more of the
newspapers aren't reporting on the
problems with the booster program which
are
extensive because there are some people
who have been able to have their booster
they have been able to book or they've
been able to walk in um to centers but
jake what do you make of this if you've
we've got nicolas sturgeon saying that
we've got a tsunami heading our way and
a million cases by january
do you think we're going to get the
booster program on track by then
well i mean i'm i'm sure um susie's
experience was was was bad
and uh and i'm sure that many people do
have a similar experience to not be able
to access the boosters when they need
them but i think it does depend on which
region the country that you're in i mean
i had my booster
some weeks ago and it was very smooth
and easy to get it
and if you look at the figures about 20
million people have had the booster so
far in britain which is getting on for
about a third of the population
so you know this stuff is happening
people are getting boosters um you know
20 million of them so far uh and i think
that you know while there are flaws in
the rollout as susie has pointed out i
think on the whole the booster uh
rollout is uh is a success story so far
but we need to build on that i mean the
fact that uh omricon is so infectious
combines with the with the knowledge now
uh that boosters do provide 75
um
protection at least uh means only one
thing that we've got to get more people
having boosters more quickly because the
alternative to that uh is more
restrictions and we know that that has
implications in terms of the economy in
terms of mental health in terms of
domestic abuse in terms of education in
terms of people's health not being able
to get the treatment they need and all
the things that we've all suffered over
the past couple of years and so you know
i think that's why the papers are really
focusing on this good news in a in a bad
situation which is that that the you
know three jabs do work against omri con
and i would like the government to take
that similar view and really focus on
the solution which is getting boosted
out properly rather than going towards
restrictions which have a lot of other
unwanted side effects
the daily telegraph picking up on that
that new data from the uk hsa
the health security agency saying that
um boosters give 75
protection against omicron susie what do
you think because the times are saying
that daily tests and pub passports are
being considered do you think that
inevitably we are going to see new
restrictions
i think we need to think of them as
safety measures you know because um
being asked to prove your vaccine status
is is is easy as winking or i have a
clean lateral flow test it's really
really easy and it's not a massive curve
on your freedoms or all the things that
you want to do with your day some of the
things that jake was talking about there
you know having full lockdowns and
sending people home from schools and not
letting people go around to you know
make the checks they should do on people
those are big restrictions but what
we're talking about here for plan b are
some fairly mild safety measures that
just limit social mixing and that's a
good thing especially if it stops people
who are unvaccinated perhaps spreading
uh the disease in amongst people who are
vaccinated like me but who just aren't
able to get their boosters yet but part
of the problem is that this booster
program started late because the jcvi
made a ruling late as far as the
government was concerned on top of that
um the requirement to test before travel
to come into this country happened late
again about a fortnight or a week or so
after the labour party suggested it to
the government and then you've got plan
b actually being put into action a
fortnight after the sage scientist said
we're going to need this for omicron
because you can't stop omicron coming in
you can't stop new variants but all you
can do is slow it down and if you're
going to slow it down you have to slow
it down right at the start you can't
wait until it's here and suddenly it
starts looking bad because then it's you
know you've lost it it's gone that's
what we're seeing now is that
exponential spread and unfortunately
it's the same kind of story i had last
year doing things too late because we
don't want to have you know curb
people's freedoms because that seems to
be more important than saving people's
lives and that is where we are there's
no point going on about it but we really
need as jake said to get the booster
rolled out and make sure that that's in
the arms but i think
while we're waiting and we are gonna
have to wait because there's only a
third of the country that has that
booster at the moment two-thirds don't
so they are vulnerable uh and there's
gonna have to be some um
measures to stop social mixing or to
slow it down in order to protect us
while we're waiting for that booster
programme to catch up with where we need
it to be it must be really worrying if
you've had too astrazenica um and you're
waiting to get your booster and you
can't get it um let's look at this okay
sorry say that again susie
i'm category six i'm in one of the
vulnerable groups i hope you can get it
soon
uh
daily mirror france's daily mirror
interesting it's been a
rather a week for boris johnson hasn't
it um jake what do you think about the
backlash
from those alleged christmas parties um
and the mirror saying that that scandal
leaves four in five less likely to
follow covert rules
as we see infection rates rise every day
this is a real problem for the
government i mean it shows how you know
a personal problem for for the prime
minister
in terms of people's perception of his
integrity can bleed out into real
real world consequences in terms of the
number of people who are prepared to
actually take the government's mandates
seriously when it comes to covid and to
follow them uh you know it's the two
things that are directly linked i mean
it's one thing for the government if for
boris johnson to have a kind of you know
sort of happy-go-lucky rambunctious
relationship with
um with with you know what he says to
people and you know we know what what
sort of a character boris is defying
gravity getting away with things telling
white lies maybe sort of stretching
things a little bit and all that you
know we know who he is and that was okay
when he was a journalist in a way unless
you were his wife um but it's not okay
now when he's making
it's not okay now when he's making you
know serious government policy that's
life or death for uh for millions of
people and so i think that really um you
know you know what what needs to be done
you know to take things away from the
prime minister's prime minister a little
bit and back into the principle of
policymaking
uh i'm much more in favor of giving
people um information
to assess their own level of risk
rather than
mandating working from home as a blunt
instrument across the board and
unfortunately the government is going
for those you know big ticket
restrictions increasingly but the
problem is that the authority that the
prime minister uh has had to to uh sort
of command people to do that has been
eroded and that's where the government
finds itself right now
okay let's leave it there for the time
being susie jake thanks a lot we're
gonna go for a break and coming up the
call to keep schools open after the
christmas break despite those concerns
over omicron
[Music]
hello again you're watching the press
preview with me this evening the daily
mirror columnist susie boniface and the
editor of the jewish chronicle jake
wallace simons um susie jake thanks a
lot for joining us let's look at the
telegraph front page keep the schools
open come up may because that is always
the worry isn't it that schools will
close jake
yeah i mean you know i've got three kids
and just to see the effects of the
long-term home schooling
last winter
is proof enough that we've got to try
our
hardest
to keep those schools open
um and it just makes sense in all sorts
of ways you know children are not
affected as badly uh from kobe uh thank
god as uh as adults are um you know and
i think that the long-term harm
of uh cutting off their education uh is
is awful for them as individuals uh and
for their generation
and for our economy as a whole and for
our society i think that we need to take
these things really seriously and just
have that as a goal to keep schools open
um you know and just do whatever we can
in terms of maybe masks or some
distancing or or whatever it is
to enable to do everything we can to
make it as safe as possible but i would
be very very reluctant to push the
button of
starting to close schools
susie why were you shaking your head
um because the the variants we have at
the moment have shown that a little
under 10 of children who've had covid uh
have symptoms more than five weeks they
have long covered
and although they don't die and they're
not in this death statistics the people
who have long covered which is about 14
of the adults and just under like i said
10 of the children we don't know the
long-term effects of long-covered we
don't know how any of them are going to
get over a multi-system sort of viral
after effect um which has been seen
after previous flu epidemics as well
it's that's a big issue and we don't
know the long-term effects of those so
while i agree with jake we've got to try
and keep the schools open
we can't say children are unharmed by
kovid that's that's a fallacy and it's
something that came out of i think the
first way when when so many elderly
people died we forgot about the fact it
does affect children too and there's a
long covered aspect which affects those
who survive
okay um we'll leave it there we're going
to go to a break we will of course see
you at 11 thank you both susie and jake